officials warning us about the
coronavirus threat are increasingly
worried that baby boomers Anthony mesas
not listening to their advice it's a
particular problem in Florida where some
beaches are still open and college
students on break have been slow to
recognize the danger Manuel Bojorquez is
in Hollywood Florida that's a place
where you find a lot of Spring Breakers
and retirees many hello to you a young
friend of mine said to me yesterday that
the government sends conflicting
messages that they leave the beaches
open and then tell young people not to
go so do you think people are now
finally going to get the message here's
what I can tell you from reporting on
this story this week some young people
just will not budge and it requires
doing something like this actually
shutting down the beaches to get their
attention but this decision does not
come lightly in a state where tourism is
an eighty six billion dollar a year
industry
if packed beaches weren't enough to get
your blood boiling
there was this now some young adults
seemed to be getting the message that
they can spread the virus and become
severely ill themselves even if they had
to learn at the hard way
they're starting to all get positive
tests this Vanderbilt University senior
who asked we not use his name is now one
of a number of students who tested
positive for the corona virus at that
school because of that I just sort of
rapid spread everyone's really worried I
have a friend and like most old friends
in the hospital right now I think that
the narrative is completely flipped if
you go out now
you're gonna get shamed from a lot of
people officials are trying to reach
young people by any means possible the
Surgeon General asked influencers like
Kylie Jenner to spread the message
please stay inside you guys please stay
inside practice social distancing self
quarantine New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo brought his 22 year old daughter
Makayla to a news conference to show
she's staying put it makes no sense to
go expose yourself to these conditions
and expose other people 74 year old
arrow
i singer of Fort Lauderdale agrees but
what if you could say something to them
what would you say I would say just be
aware of what is going on and take it
seriously he's part of the quarter of
Florida's population over 60 a
concerning statistic in a state up until
recently full of tourists the governor
has been criticized for not ordering all
beaches closed when people put out some
of these pictures that were you know at
the beginning of the weekend when CDC's
guidance said 250 people is fine chimed
changed radically in 72 hours and so
we've responded a lot of local
communities have responded but
miami-dade County didn't close all
beaches until yesterday Clearwater Beach
is closing today we also found when it
comes to young people the reverse can
also be true many say they're finding it
hard to convince their parents to change
their routines my dad is in sales and
he's he's the baby-boomer go get her and
last time I talked to him he was still
out moving and grooving
in the end this weekend will be
drastically different than the last some
hotels are having to close due to lack
of demand and other hotels like those
along the Florida Keys they are being
ordered to close starting Sunday at 6
p.m.
Tony Manny thank you very much moving
and grooving are you moving in group it
is no fun Anthony to be chastised by
your children is it can your daughter
say to Michael yes my 24 year old
daughter got on my case where were you
going I I was I was going to it with Jim
and she was like your gym is closing I
was like this but it's not closed yet I
have to say message received and then I
look at the younger people if you're not
gonna think about yourself at least
think about your parents or your
grandparents message that you're putting
them in jeopardy federal government was
wrong maybe about marijuana but they're
not wrong about coronavirus impressed
with my daughter Chester what are they
calling it a Boomer reducer no you don't
to be in that group I hope also mom and
dad who's paying like generations ease
bills whether they're partying on the
beach or pulling the plug yeah cancelled
yeah